Jim is with us in Dallas welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Tim Timothy Ramsey
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I'm calling is here what
would they do question my life and I
have been praying about a remodel for
the last eight months just to add a
little color to the back story we bought
a home eight months ago and moved in
with the intention of living there for
two years in order to save up and pay
for the remodel throughout buying it we
found out that there was serious about
three months in we found out there's
serious piping and the plumbing issues
where some sewage have been leaking
underneath the house there are two
bellies and the pipes and I needed a ton
of work we just gave birth to our fourth
child within that time we tried to patch
it it still produced other problems
therefore we decided in November of last
year to move out and go ahead with the
remodel we have plans to move for the
remodel next week we are going to spend
$500,000 on the remodel which we have
cash for but my wife and I are
struggling if it's the right thing to do
a $500,000 remodel yes sir
that's a bunch that's almost like
pushing it down and starting again what
is the magic that makes you want to do
that with it what's the price range of
this house yes sir we bought a house for
400,000 then you're gonna spend five
hundred on it and then it'll be worth
what about nine seventy five okay so the
reason you would do this is not because
you're gonna have instant equity because
it's not if I spent nine hundred on a
hat five hundred on our four hundred
thousand dollar house I'd want it to be
worth one point six I would want not not
make seventy five thousand on all of
that because I mean here's the thing you
could spend all this effort it's gonna
take a ton of your time and your
emotional energy already have yeah in
your emotional energy and it could you
know and you're really not getting
anything for that other than this finish
product so is the finished product
that's special we bought the house
because of the lot in the neighborhood
and so is the finished product special
yes it would be what we think is our
dream house but much it's like I go back
and I go forth and I seek counsel and I
seek other people and I I still I still
cannot get over the barrier I mean why
could you not buy the house in the same
neighborhood with that's already been
renovated for 975 in a similar lot a lot
probably not the home we probably could
find something like that there's only 15
half acre or bigger Lots in the area
[Applause]
then I guess my point is is that you
could take your money if you sold the
house for what you've got in at only and
you didn't make any money on it at all
you got you sold it for 400 getting 900
thousand dollars in your pocket for that
kind of money you can buy we don't own
them either so I have a $300,000
mortgage out on it oh I say you don't
have it paid for it is in your name but
you have a mortgage okay
correct and the 500,000 is in cash you
borrowed that money or yes sir that is
what we have saved up over the last five
years okay in order to do this deal well
we have been praying about a home and a
lot and and we we found this home and
this lot and decided to buy it and then
sold our home that we were we were in a
new renovation have y'all done zero okay
and how old are you 32 what do you do
for a living I'm in haled okay what's
your wife do for a living she's a
full-time mama for kids yeah and you're
a really good salesman okay you make
some Bank okay good all right there's
two times two two ways to lenses we can
look at this let's look at it through
both of them okay let's look at it
through a pure
real estate transaction I don't like it
as a pure real estate transaction I'm
not mad about it if you want to go ahead
I won't call you stupid but if if I were
on the bubble I would lean away from
doing it because you're an inexperienced
renovator getting ready to do a very
expensive renovation and if you're off
only 10% it's a $50,000 error on the
estimation of this process here and and
you're emotionally already kind of sound
like you're drained with this thing just
talking to me I'm by the time you get
done with this you may wish you had
never seen real estate and when you
finish you're only gonna have $75,000
and you know to show for it equity that
for fun I you know if I'm gonna have
nine hundred and something and go to all
this dad-blame trouble I really would
like to have a property worth a million
six I'd like to have some equity for all
my sweat that you're putting into this
that's what I'm saying so on the real
estate only front that's how I would
analyze it I'm a very experienced
renovator I've owned thousands of
properties we buy property all the time
we do we own commercial property that we
you know have to do tenant improvements
on I'm very familiar with the
construction in the renovation process I
would not do this deal because there's
not enough room in it to make it fun as
an experienced investor the again nine
hundred invested over seventy five over
nine seventy five being the value so
that's my real estate analysis again I
don't think you're stupid if you love
the lot and it just is your dream come
true that's fine I just don't watch your
dream to become a nightmare and that's
what I'm afraid of
now that's what's one lens okay let's
switch gears let's look at this you
mentioned two times or three times you
were praying about this and so from a
Christian perspective from a faith walk
perspective I look at three things when
I'm making a large decision like this is
the action that I mean that I'm engaging
in contrary to biblical principles is it
biblical number one number two is the
timing right and then number three do I
have P
about it and if I don't get peace about
something in my spirit that is as big a
project as this is in your life I don't
go forward if the timing is off or if I
ascertain that it's not biblical so in
my sense I strongly believe the Bible
does not tell us to borrow money as a
matter of fact it tells us several times
not to and so if I had to borrow money
to do it I wouldn't do it because it's
not biblical it violates one of those
three things right or if I just don't
have enough time to mess with what's
going on even if it's a great idea and
it's a biblical idea and I kind of like
I'm kind of excited about but I just
don't have time my calendar my plates
too full I'll push it off just because
the timing is off and I call that God
speaking to me on the timing okay or if
I just can't get settled about it and my
wife can't get settled about it the two
of us together on a decision like this
have to have a deep abiding peace and
that's different than house fever that's
different than I'm excited about a
purchase or a final product that's
different I just am disturbed inside and
I want that peace that passes
understanding and I use those as as a as
a Christian and it sounds like you are I
use those as guidance mechanisms what
does what does that idea say to you I
agree no I mean that's like all you
doesn't do you have peace you know I
feel like I have had peace in the
process of the last three months of
planning this mm-hmm
I've had days of peace but it's come to
the point of signing this away and
starting the process and I feel like I
feel overwhelmed by it I feel I feel not
peaceful and I laid awake with my wife
last night until to thinking about this
and talking about this again so we have
done this for so long so here's what's
gonna happen every time there is a
hiccup in this renovation process and
you and I know there's gonna be a bunch
of them you know you're gonna go in a
freakout mode man yeah you're gonna
second you're gonna second-guess
yourself this is gonna turn into a
nightmare I don't think I don't think
your general
concept is bad but I think the Holy
Spirit might be talking to you I think
you might be very clearly talking to you
in the middle of night last night you do
what you want to do I'm not I'm not
saying God said this I'm just saying
that's how I make decisions and I'm just
listening to you brother and you're good
man you got a good heart you've done a
good job saving money so you do what you
want if I woke up in your shoes I'd
probably sell this house and use my
money to buy something else